from the police it sounds interesting it
makes you sound like you're on the
Vanguard of cultural Trends and you know
saying like rethink reimagine law
enforcement suddenly you sound like a
sophisticated and interesting but those
ideas have Downstream effects on less
fortunate people who don't wield the
same level of influence in society
they're the ones who get to pay the cost
of those luxury beliefs that Garner you
status among your peers
all right guys bang bang I've got Rob
here with me uh Rob I thought a great
place to start this conversation is this
idea of luxury beliefs you're the first
person that I've heard ever bring this
up and it's one of those ideas that once
you see it you can't unsee it you start
to kind of take this framework and start
to map it to all these different things
in society but describe first like what
is a luxury belief right luxury beliefs
I defined as ideas and opinions that
confer status on the upper class well
often inflicting costs on the lower
classes and there are multiple
components to to this concept this
framework
um you know we can I'll sort of give a
summary of the idea and the pieces and
then you know we don't jump into
questions and so essentially you know
historically the upper Strat of society
have always found ways to stand out to
distinguish themselves my claim is that
historically it's been done through
luxury goods through material Goods
through the clothing people uh would
wear the uh sort of accoutrements they
would display the possessions that they
owned but over time time material Goods
have become a noisier signal of one's
social position so a hundred years ago
you could look at someone and
immediately tell whether they were rich
or poor just by their appearance and
what they were wearing and where they
lived and so forth whereas today it's
it's less true I'm not saying like
material goods are are no longer a
reliable indicator status just noisier
however the upper class today the the
cultural Elites the Elise of society
still wants to
um display their prominence and so the
new way that they do this is through
their luxury beliefs through fashionable
ideas through Trends through holding uh
peculiar and and you know interesting
and sometimes bizarre ideas that are at
odds with conventional opinion and this
is sort of an expression of what the
sociologist Pierre Perdue described as
cultural capital so luxury beliefs are a
sort of expression of cultural capital
you can only obtain these ideas if you
uh attend a an expensive University you
read the right periodicals you hang out
with the right Social Circle the right
crowd read the right books and all all
of the the luxury beliefs these opinions
that you express are indicators of where
you stand in society and we can get into
specific examples yeah what's an example
of like a luxury belief that most people
would recognize uh well the most
probably recent luxury belief that I
think a lot of people uh will will
remember as the defund the police
movement uh so this gained a lot of
popularity in 2020 uh at one point it
was abolished the police then it sort of
shifted to defund the police
um and so we've sort of seen some of the
consequences of this so so defund the
police became fashionable among cultural
leads in 2020
and so this shifted attitudes around law
enforcement and policing some of it was
implemented in an actual policy in
certain States and certain regions uh
and various forms of crime have
increased since then as a result but
there was a popular uh there was a
yougov survey in 2020 which uh asked a
representative sample of Americans uh
you know do you want to defund the
police essentially and the group that
was the most supportive of defunding the
police uh if you break down by by income
the highest income category they were
the most supportive by far of defunding
the police relative to the middle and
lower income categories
um I mean and also relatedly
um in I think this was actually in
Minneapolis white residents of
Minneapolis were more supportive of
defunding the police than black
residents and so this is a an example
defund the police it sounds interesting
it makes you sound uh um like you sort
of have like you're on the Vanguard of
cultural Trends and you know saying like
rethink reimagine law enforcement
suddenly you sound like a sophistic
educated and interesting but those ideas
have Downstream effects on less
fortunate people who don't wield the
same level of influence in society
they're the ones who get to pay the cost
of those luxury beliefs that Garner you
status among your peers so when people
watch like I'll call like an old school
movie or a movie that you know kind of
about some point in history I think a
lot about like the aristocracy right and
like these people who were above
something that everyone else did right
um
and what I think I've learned from you
which is really interesting is like some
of these ideas can morph they can
actually be widely accepted in one
portion of you know kind of uh income
distribution and then those people can
actually turn on the idea and I think
Hamilton is something that you use as an
example maybe you can kind of describe
like
a luxury belief is not just something
that is like a static thing it can
actually morph and evolve over time and
the wealthiest people
can actually turn on themselves in some
weird way yeah yeah it's well it's it's
sort of dynamic I I
um draw an analogy to to Fashion where
once uh you know like a fur coat may
become very popular For That season but
once enough people wear it it sort of
loses
um loses its its status it's its
legitimacy as uh as as a sort of a a
marker status so uh an example given is
actually with a Canada Goose jackets so
when I was an undergrad at Yale
um a few years ago
um you know the the the Kennedy Goose
jacket was very popular in say like the
mid-2010s and then once you were able to
get them at discount prices and at
outlet stores and so on suddenly you
know you don't really see that many
Canada Goose jackets uh on Elite college
campuses anymore uh and so
uh the idea is dynamic the Hamilton idea
um I I wrote about this in an op-ed in
the Wall Street Journal a couple of
years ago which was that so when
Hamilton first came out in 2015 tickets
were inordinately expensive only a
select few could could even get tickets
to get access to to be able to see this
show and the the cultural Elites loved
it you know sort of everywhere everyone
was talking about it and uh if you had
seen Hamilton this was like a big deal
like wow you saw Hamilton wow and uh and
I remember this is 2015 I looked up
tickets and they were way outside of my
my budget as a you know a veteran on in
college on the GI bill just you know I
wasn't gonna be able to get a ticket for
that
um but then uh in 2020 uh suddenly
Disney plus announced that they were
going to start airing they start to
stream Hamilton on their platform and
shortly thereafter suddenly people
started to turn on Hamilton and it
became unfashionable the Creator started
to to sort of broadcast the criticisms
of his own show and people sort of
turned on this and the reason is because
it became too popular became too
fashionable suddenly everyone had access
to Hamilton it couldn't be cool anymore
it could only be cool if it's exclusive
and only a certain number of people uh
have access to it and the same is kind
of true with luxury beliefs once a
belief becomes too popular or uh too
widely held then it becomes passe and
people must move on to the next luxury
belief so when you think about
um kind of that Dynamic nature of it how
much of the change is driven by the rich
people versus the non-rich people like
is it actually the only people who can
change the uh kind of position of an
idea is the you know if you will like
taste maker like like you have to be in
the luxury belief category to actually
be able to say no that idea is no longer
luxury or does it come from the other
side of the spectrum uh well I think the
the luxury beliefs they they have to
so so where they originate can vary
um some people have asked me you know
can can luxury beliefs go in the reverse
Direction Where maybe they start with uh
the the lower classes and then perhaps
like cause cause harm somehow sort of
goes the other way and cars causes harm
to the upper classes I don't think this
is the case because the people who wield
the most influence in society are the
upper classes so even if an idea
originates among sort of more
marginalized groups in society it's the
the upper class the the people who wield
social influence who get to pick that
idea up from them and then amplify it
and broadcast it to everyone else uh and
so yeah it can it can it can it can
originate with with certain groups more
than others or it can originate anywhere
really but the people who are
responsible for for broadcasting and
amplifying it are are members of the
upper class the affluent so the affluent
and upper class one of the things I I've
really wanted to kind of talk through
with you is can it also vary from
Community to community and what I mean
by this is
um if I go to uh Greenwich Connecticut
I'll pick on them right and I say to you
hey who's the affluent people in
Greenwich Connecticut everyone has a
generalization in their mind right it's
like a hedge fund manager right who like
uh you know probably has too much money
for doing too little and uh they'd set
the culture of that area and their peer
groups Etc but if I then take you to you
know I don't know maybe the 1980s or
1990s and I asked you who is setting the
culture for hip-hop as is becoming
popular those two people don't look
alike they don't make nearly the same
amount of money or anything but in some
weird way you know what now has become
multi-billionaires and very wealthy
people from kind of hip-hop Community
there was almost this like Street
culture and I wonder is their luxury
beliefs even though it's Street culture
even though it's not you know the hedge
fund community and the super wealthy can
there still be luxury beliefs within
kind of these smaller you know or kind
of maybe not yet affluent communities
that are not mirrored by the hedge fund
manager Etc yeah that's interesting I
mean yeah so so the
there can be the sort of factional
Elites different groups different
communities that that broadcast the
beliefs and and hold different kinds of
beliefs that's yeah that's an
interesting example I can I can imagine
that that like if you within a community
if you hold status within that Community
however the status is conferred maybe
it's it's conferred differently among
like uh like uh business Moguls or
musicians or something versus hedge fund
managers and So within that group but I
think like there's there's been a sort
of convergence among a lot of the elites
where you know if you work in a creative
industry or your head should fund
manager there's been this this sort of
integration among cultural and economic
Elites where you know generally there's
a lot of overlap now but I I think that
yeah even among the Elites in say yeah
hip-hop or or rock or something like
that if you sort of earn your money
through promoting values that could hurt
those below you within that Community an
example is like a glorification of drug
use right like if you're a musician and
you're talking about how great it is to
do drugs and party and so on if you're
you know a multi-millionaire musician
you know you can afford whatever
potential consequence would result from
that you can afford doctors and rehab
and therapy and so on to deal with uh uh
spiraling drug addiction
but the people within your community uh
who who love your music if they get into
the same sort of habits and Lifestyles
as you they don't have the same sort of
safety net and so I think this is
something that that like all of us could
could think about when we start to
broadcast ideas when we have platforms
and and positions of prominence another
area where if you take kind of luxury
beliefs and you apply it to you know
quote the real world right is um Can it
manifest in weird ways and the example I
always jump to is like the opioid crisis
in some way the opioid crisis is
affecting uh blue collar America kind of
you know West Virginia Pennsylvania
Etc
another hand it's like white women
sitting at home taking pills in the
morning right who basically don't have a
lot of other things to do yeah now those
are two overly generalized uh kind of
groups they're taking the same exact
pill they're both addicted to it one
starts taking it because they have pain
or they're miserable or or whatever with
their day-to-day life and usually it's
money related Etc the other though like
they do share some commonalities maybe
they actually have some sort of mental
pain maybe they actually do have uh some
sort of boredom or or whatever it may
not be money driven but they're taking
that same pill and like is there some
sort of stratification or like luxury
belief that's manifesting itself in
something like the opioid crisis uh
potentially I think the the opioid
crisis there are probably multiple
moving parts to that and and how luxury
belief sends her in
um so essentially I mean there's been
this sort of shift in the culture away
from promoting certain kinds of values
and
and I think part of this is because
we're we're lucky to talk about values
now a lot of our discussion when it
comes to disparities in Social outcomes
or why some people are addicted to
opioids and so on is because of uh
purely
um sort of financial concerns and I
don't think this is completely true I
mean I know there's been sort of shifts
around the economy and the Rust Belt and
so on which contribute to this
but also
um you know there are there are other
sources of meaning and value in life
beyond beyond your job or Beyond how
much money you earn and we're also
seeing uh among sort of the lower middle
and working classes and and the people
who are lower on the socioeconomic
strata uh less marriage uh more divorce
family formation a lot of sort of social
dysfunction I mean I see it a lot of
this in in my own adoptive family as
well I mean these are sort of working
class white people who live in
California and Oregon and I'm seeing
those sort of changes over time where
my my grandparents My adoptive
grandparents I mean they were married
for 60 years uh you know never really
had any sort of serious domestic issues
despite
um being poorer than uh my generation or
my my parents generation uh my
grandparents were poor and yet they had
very few uh of these issues and when
their children my uncles and you know
aunts and cousins and so on like a lot
of them actually have issues with
opioids with unemployment with divorce
with addiction and all these problems uh
despite not having
um but despite not being as poor as my
grandparents and a lot of this is just
sort of changes in the culture access to
drug use a lot of these things right
like people are earning money from these
drugs
um people are garnering status for
um sort of questioning or challenging or
undermining uh values around family
information as well so all of these
things I think are contributing to this
sort of stratification where if you're
an upper class person you're you're
educated you've lived in a stable
environment in your entire life you sort
of learn that oh if I uh you know if I
get married and sort of follow these
steps if I work hard and so on even if
you say otherwise right this is the
luxury beliefs idea is that you you
personally in your private life work
very hard but then private or publicly
your public opinion is you know oh hard
work doesn't matter it's all luck anyway
or whatever right you sort of downplay
it so personally you actually know what
you have to do
but if you uh come from a less educated
more marginalized background and no one
is there to guide you uh to tell you to
take certain steps to hey if you have
children it's probably better to get
married first these kinds of things
um even if you know it to have it
reinforced repeatedly by the people
around you the way that you might in an
upper upper middle class neighborhood
um
that can have long-term detrimental
consequences and so this is why I think
we see a lot of sort of single
Parenthood a lot of addiction uh and a
lot of other social ills in these
communities I've said before that a lot
of society's problems not all but a lot
of them would be drastically improved
and or solved if we just had better
parents right yeah um and you kind of
look around and there's people in the
news every single day that do stuff and
you're kind of just like where are their
parents right
um and it's much easier to kind of uh uh
come to that conclusion when it's a
young person right than let's say a 30
or 40 year old person
um but there is this element of values
and so uh Clayton Christensen is very
well known for the innovator slimo but
he also wrote this book uh how will you
measure your life great book and in it
he talks about
um you know there's an entire generation
of people who are basically Outsourcing
the raising of their children so again
probably a luxury belief or related uh
if you have access to money and you want
to put other things in front of spending
time with your child people like oh I
would never do that well you may put
them in school for certain reasons you
may use in the example of like you keep
them in sports because it keeps them
constantly doing things and it frees up
your time to go do something else yeah
you are Outsourcing to some degree even
if a small degree uh the raising of your
children and he says be careful then say
don't do it but be careful because you
are Outsourcing the instillment of the
values of your child yeah and so what's
fascinating to me is like this idea of
values I think a lot of people would
just say like oh there's been a
degradation of religion in America and
so if religion goes down that's really
tied to values and kind of those being
reinforced but I don't know if that's
necessarily true one and then I guess
also are there societies around the
world that we could learn from where
whether they have high degree of
religion adoption or not values have
stayed you know kind of a core part of
the culture even in the modern world
with the internet and kind of all the
things that Americans have access to but
values still persist and they don't seem
to have the same problems that we have
here whereas an international kind of
issue yeah it's it's a good point
um to do the earlier thing you said
about about raising uh kids and
Outsourcing it I think like even even
the like the values issue is important
but then also
um we I think like it's it's still a
question in terms of how Outsourcing
kids and having someone else raise them
will have not just
um consequences for what values they
hold but then also sort of their their
development and and self-concept and
these kinds of things a a friend of mine
the author Mary Harrington had pointed
out to me the other day and I were
talking and she suggested that um a lot
of the kind of concerns around safety in
our culture is due to this sort of
hiring of of nannies and other people
and so on and her reasoning is basically
that if you if you're a parent and
you're and I know you have a young child
and you're walking with your child and
they're playing on the monkey bars
they're doing something a little bit
dangerous or Reckless you're there to
monitor them and you'll maybe allow them
to take a little bit of risk but if
you're a babysitter or a nanny or a maid
you're not going to let the kid ever do
anything dangerous because you're liable
for it right you're going to be making
sure they never do anything dangerous
ever and if the kid goes up that way you
know anytime they might do something a
bit Reckless and the nanny immediately
interferes then suddenly concerns about
safety take on greater import right and
so this is I think something that that
uh at least for me I found that that to
be intriguing is basically there's a
coddling of the individual not
necessarily just a society thing it's
because the direct like manager of the
child essentially is covering their ass
yeah exactly which is it's irrational
and reasonable from the nanny's
perspective to not let the kid do
anything dangerous but long term if a
kid grows up that way this may have
unforeseen consequences and maybe we're
seeing some of those consequences now
among sort of upper middle class young
people
and so the question of values yeah it's
I mean it's it's I think those two
things kind of they they correlate but I
think they they can be separable I mean
they're like the secularization of
Western societies I think we can see
that maybe there was there was uh like
the morality tied to religion in some
way but then there are other cultures uh
in uh in Asia for example like in
Singapore they seem to have pretty
strong values despite not being
especially religious uh Japan as well
you know some of the Asian cultures
there maybe maybe a sort of a
Counterpoint that you don't necessarily
have to have strong religion in order to
have good social values but those are
very different cultures than than the
West right I mean it's it's possible
that some cultures actually need
religion more than others in order to uh
to flourish and for people who are less
fortunate to have those cultural
guardrails around them
um so so yeah I don't I don't
necessarily think religion is is
required but if it's if we're not going
to have it it would be I think important
one one message I you know I I would
have with these luxury beliefs is that
if you
um wield any kind of influence in
society to to really consider like what
what consequences those your your
broadcasting of certain beliefs and
opinions and ideas will have and to
consider like you know maybe maybe
Beyond
um
a lot of a lot of Elites they want to
have conversations around money and the
way that they think is best to help
marginalized and poor and so on the
dispossessed is to just give them more
money to redistribute money I'm not
opposed to economic or financial
assistance I think that and that's by
and large that's actually a good thing
but there are other ways to lead a
flourishing life in addition to
promoting sort of economic assistance to
also sort of share values that you know
can reliably lead to a flourishing life
as well I mentioned some of them earlier
things like like hard work things like
marriage things like uh you know putting
others needs before your own a lot of
the values that a lot of upper and upper
middle class people practice in their
everyday lives they uh they're just very
reluctant to say publicly uh and often
and sometimes I don't believe that I
mean you and I talked earlier that if
you if sometimes if you say these things
publicly people will criticize you for
them I I think we should all maybe uh
develop you know a thick enough skin to
just say it you know I get I get
attacked on social media for some things
but I think it's important that these
are things that need to be be understood
and sort of reinforced repeatedly in the
culture
um how do we do them
well I I think yeah firstly a
recognition of it right that it is
important for us to
broadcast uh values and habits that we
know can can help not always not in
every case I'm you know I'm not saying
like you know if everybody works hard
then everyone's Gonna Be A Millionaire
that's not how this you know but on
average right like any given person and
you can see this with how people
communicate with their own children with
their own families right I um
uh there's a there's a um story that
I've written about before about a a
friend of mine from high school he
uh he was failing one of his classes so
he he was on track to be recruited to
play uh football uh for a state school
in California and he was failing a class
he had to attend a makeup class for two
weeks and get a B that's all I needed
just attendance class get a b and you
could be on your on on your on your way
to college he attended for three days
and then bailed and then you know went
and screwed around with me and all of
our other friends and just decided not
to go he had like the rest of me and my
friends growing very little supervision
at home
I told this story uh to one of my
classmates at Cambridge and uh and her
response was interesting to me she she
said like well if that's like what your
friend wanted to do and that's who he
was like maybe it's okay like maybe he
shouldn't maybe he wasn't like messing
to go to college maybe that's not
College wasn't for him and I said Okay
if that was your son what would you have
done and she said oh I would make sure
that he goes to class and I would
threaten to kill him if he didn't
and I said okay so it's okay for my
friends and I to ruin our futures but
for your kids it's definitely not right
like there's this sort of inconsistent
standards in terms of
what people are willing to promote when
it comes to their own loved ones they
want them to do the things that will
lead to success but when it comes to
others they adopt this sort of
non-judgmental impartial oh it's okay
you know if that's who you are I don't
want to you know I don't wanna but you
inevitably like that that in itself is a
value judgment non-judgmentalism is like
I'm going to step back and not help
um or not promote certain values that in
itself is a judgment so we don't get to
decide not to have any kind of influence
on society either way there's going to
be an effect on on the rest of society
so
having this recognition and being
willing to you know accept some of the
slings and arrows for promoting these
views I think that would be step one
when you see that happening right so
I've got a young daughter uh too young
for me to have to really worry about
some of those types of things but also
um it's fascinating to me of
um hey let somebody kind of figure their
way out versus there is a very direct
path right and if you want to do X this
is you do a b and c and some uh uh
professions it's very clear you want to
be a doctor got to go to college yeah
right like it's not really a path unless
you go to college
um but then there's other things you
know if you want to be go to the other
end of the stream a painter there's a
whole bunch of different ways that you
could do including like let's go get
some paint you just do whatever you want
in your basement right and then you can
figure it out from there yeah and so
when you kind of look at Society in
general I do wonder how much of hey let
people kind of figure it out versus like
the prescription of okay we need more
doctors so we need to go and almost look
at it as a math problem we need you know
2 000 doctors to graduate this year that
means that we need 10 000 people to
start medical school or you know
whatever the numbers are right and that
means that we need uh you know 50 000 of
them to be interested as freshmen in
high school and like almost look at it
as like these pipelines now I know
companies think of it in some cases like
this especially big companies that are
worried about uh Talent you know Amazons
and people like that but I do wonder how
much of society would benefit from like
the schools right and I always think
about the the uh classic example of
um the like career development person or
like the college counselor type person
where I have friends who are like oh I
went in and they were like yeah you
should go to Community College and it's
like they're basically taking a student
and they're just slotting them into like
you're definitely going to Community
College yeah and someone along the way
was like hey man you can go to a
four-year University or like you can do
this or this and like show them
possibility rather than just like kind
of the deterministic path of a college
counselor yeah yeah and so like man how
important is that person's role right
yeah but also like what they're saying
to these kids and how much I can really
kind of uh influence what they end up
becoming in their life yeah yeah no no
no I I think that having having mentors
having people who can sort of spot
potential and and to promote it and
cultivate it and and and also just like
sometimes kids aren't even aware that
they have it I mean when I was in school
a lot of teachers would would sort of
point it out to me and I think in the
moment I I
resisted it and wouldn't take it
seriously but it would remain in my mind
like it did sort of change my
self-concept and my image of myself
after a while but I think like those two
things like having having mentors having
you know guidance counselors teachers
other other adults along the way pointed
out that's important but then also like
the family issue is important too
because at least for me and a lot of my
friends
um like it was like we we sort of
because we were having the the the
teachers and people around us recognize
this
um because our home lives were so
chaotic it was just not a priority for
us to do well in life so for I'll give
you an example so I uh I did really well
in Middle School
[Music]
um
and I got placed into some some higher
level courses in high school and I was
placed into chemistry and things were
suddenly like there was a reversal and
things were going very badly in my life
and my family and my grades plummeted
and chemistry was actually like a pretty
challenging course where I would
actually have to pay attention if I
wanted to pass it and upon discovering
this I was like I am not staying in this
class anymore I go to my counselor and I
say hey I want to transfer out into
nutritional science which was like the
this is like the dumb kid class like how
do I get into that class I've been in
that one
and uh and I was like ah this chemistry
thing is just too difficult he's like
and and this was so the guidance
counselor was like Hey like you're on
track to go to college like you should
stay in chemistry and just like put in
the effort like don't do this and I was
like hey man I'm taking nutritional
stuff like I don't want to say this
class this is hard and uh he's like okay
take this form you know your parents
have to sign it and come back and we'll
get you transferred to another class I
go home I forged my mom's signature go
back and say like get me a new
nutritional science like and that was a
case of me sort of thwarting my own
potential that I knew was was there on
some level but uh because of of that
family piece I just wasn't ready to uh
to pursue that path and and sort of take
myself seriously enough to do it and so
there's a lot here going on
um and again this isn't to say that that
uh mentorship and guidance isn't
important and having teachers and and
people recognize it as an important that
was important for me it just took a
while for it to finally click you know
what I mean so yeah just just a lot
going on with uh how to how to shape a
Young Person's trajectory it's funny you
say this because
um there's one there's a couple of
moments but one specific one I can think
of in my life where I still to this day
don't know if it was good mentorship or
bad mentorship which is like a very
interesting thing right yeah so uh when
I was a freshman in college
um you get there I'm playing football
there's all these older guys right and
they kind of they don't want to like be
too overbearing but they also are kind
of trying to guide you hey man like that
class is hard this one's not you know
whatever and so uh they all were like
like across the board
intro to Bible gotta take it right
okay why so like trust me and then
you're like well explain why and they're
like well you see the teacher she's the
advisor to the football team oh got it
okay okay nicest lady in the world right
been teaching this class for a long time
so I go for the first day and uh she
would have everyone stand the
classroom's only 35 people 40 people
right and so she would have everyone
stand up say your name say uh you know
what you did on campus or something and
like say something interesting about
yourself whatever like the The Prompt
was
and so I kid you now let's say the room
was 35 40 people half 50 percent
she starts in the front left corner of
the classroom first guy stands up I'm so
and so whatever I play football second
person I'm so and so I play football go
around the room up and down the aisles
half of the people are on the football
team Emma being like this is awesome all
my teammates are in here are having a
blast like all this stuff now it turns
out that actually the class was super
interesting she was a fantastic teacher
it was basically a guarantee day right
so like what they were really kind of
giving the mentorship around was like
hey this is an easy a go take this class
she'll be very sympathetic to football
players all the stuff that was true but
also it ended up being something that
was like so outside of like what you
would expect to get in a college
classroom that was like intellectually
stimulating and actually what I noticed
was like me and a bunch of other people
who probably didn't pay attention a lot
of other classes we were paying
attention right so like that was like a
weird win I always go back and I'm like
did that person give me good mentorship
because they guided me to kind of an
easy grade like all stuff or did they
actually like screw me because what they
should have told me was like go take
this really hard class where you're
actually going to learn something that's
applied to like your professional career
later on
and it kind of depends on which way you
look at it right and so I I tend to
think that sometimes advice seems really
good at one point in your life you look
back like hey that was bad advice
because I'm trying to optimize for
something else now and vice versa you
think something's really bad advice at
the time you know for example you're
like this guy wants me to stay in this
class you know whatever but no I really
want to get into nutrition science and
now you might look back and you're like
I thought it was bad advice then like
maybe that was like the best advice you
could have given me at the time right
yeah it's I think it's it's hard because
when people give advice often they're
giving advice that they would give to
themselves or they're giving advice that
that on average is the right advice
because you know a guidance counselor
can't like take the time to like get to
know every single person and figure out
like what what they're good at and what
their trajectories are but like in that
moment like if I was in that guidance
counselor's position I would do the same
thing I'd be like hey like this is a
smart kid trying to like take a class
beneath his ability what are you doing
um but yeah and it for me it kind of
worked out right like everything did end
up uh you know being okay in the end but
yeah it's it's uh the whole advice
giving game it's It's Tricky right like
how to know which advice to give which
person and then like when you're in a
position where you're sort of giving
advice to lots of people
and you don't necessarily know like how
would how each person would implement it
in their individual circumstances so
yeah yeah you don't always know you
don't always know I also think in uh
School specifically
um there's something interesting when
you look at uh let's say high schools as
an example some high schools will brag
about how many of their students got
into college and other schools will brag
about how good their school is and it's
like a very weird thing right because
like in some way if you want to brag
about on like your home page 96 of our
kids get into college that a lot of that
school is going to be focused on getting
kids into college right if instead
you're almost like patting yourself on
the back and like we're really good at
teaching kids but there's no like
measurement of it how much of the school
is focused on getting them into college
versus some other thing that they're
optimizing for yeah that's uh is that is
that good good heart's law about like
anything you optimize for cease to
become a good metric or something along
those lines right I think think yeah
there's there's some some truth to that
and yeah like on the one hand you want
you want objective metrics right like if
you yeah like you say oh we're good at
teaching kids well how do I know like
prove it and then they give you a number
they give you a figure and then suddenly
that becomes the thing that they're
they're optimizing for rather than
teaching kids uh uh well so yeah I think
uh that that can be tricky too like how
to how to balance those two things
that's sort of that holistic approach of
like ensuring they're learning but
they're not optimizing for the wrong
thing or or getting people to to sort of
hack those those numbers which a lot of
these a lot of these Elite universities
do this like I remember when I when I
applied for college and I saw on the
home page it was something like 98 of
our students graduate right 98
graduation rate
and I was like this is unreal like you
know because I'd gone to night classes
at a community college before like I was
you know like just I just knew that like
there's a lot of dropouts and a lot of
like you know a lot of other colleges
and so when I saw 90 like this is what
and then I get there you know I get to
Yale for undergrad and I learned that
like the reason why it's 98 is because
no one is allowed to fail basically like
if you if you actually don't uh like
pass if you don't do any of the
assignments like the professors will
find a way to like get you to make it up
because it's uh it's a huge hassle for
them to fail a student I'm like wait a
minute so like you get a degree from
here but it's kind of like you like they
they rig the system so that you can
graduate and that's like that's not a
good like that number on the website
obscures a lot of information how much
of an elite University is the selection
process ends up determining the elite
you know element of the school versus
the actual
um you know kind of experience or the
curriculum because I didn't go to an Ivy
League school but I went to school most
people I think would consider pretty
good Bucknell University and
same exact experience like I think you
can get an economics degree to take like
six economics classes right and you're
like hey man we're here for like four
years right like you know like like I
don't want to say it was easy because I
didn't do well to begin with right uh
and kind of learned how to do college
later in in the uh my time there but it
was very much this weird thing of like
it's it's so hard to get into these
schools and then once you're kind of
there it's unclear is that like the
system is set up that way is it just
like you become part of the herd because
everyone else is doing it so you start
to like mimic their behaviors and like
that helps you get through I I don't
know what do you think I think there's a
like all of those things are probably
true I mean they're really
um I remember the like one of the first
professors I ever met uh when I when I
transferred in they they you know he
told me um yeah it's really hard to get
in and then it's really easy to graduate
and uh like huh and so and I've heard
other people basically suggest that it's
not the degree that matters it's the
admissions letter like that's actually
what what is important for for sort of
indicating someone's uh underlying
Talent OR ability and so then the
process of of Education yeah I think
like networking sort of learning
um you know a lot of the the sort of the
decorum and the behavior and like how to
how to sort of be around these kinds of
people going to job fairs and sort of
learning what what possibilities are
before you I think all of that stuff is
important but it's terms of like actual
like academic learning I don't think
there's a lot of that going on and a lot
of that sort of washes out too I mean
there's been some interesting studies on
on education where you know you take you
take freshmen and then you test you know
you test them on some material when
they're freshmen test them on the same
material when they're seniors and
oftentimes there's not there's not a lot
of not a lot of learning going on so I
think a lot of those soft skills may may
be involved but but those are sort of
inadvertent right like that's not
ostensibly what college is forced not to
teach you those soft skills but those
are arguably the only real benefits you
you obtain social connections you were
in the military first and then went to
college
um so just by that alone you had to be
older than most of the people that you
were going to class with as an
undergraduate
um what was that experience like and was
that a thing that helped you or was that
maybe something that you felt like uh
was a setback it's a good question I
probably well it probably helped me in
that when I was 17 or 18 and I wasn't I
wasn't ready or disciplined enough to
have been a good student on my own
uh like military taught me basically
like how to be self-disciplined how to
stick to good habits how to I mean how
to be punctual I mean I was such a mess
when I was a teenager man and so you
know having that structure around me and
sort of uh inculcated Within Me by the
time I got to college when I was 25 and
I was you know I was I was you know Tech
I was seven years older officially but I
felt like I was 10 plus years older
because like the military ages you and
it is a different kind of life where
you're actually like a full-fledged
adult right and now you're with 18 year
olds who are kind of like like a
residential campus is basically uh like
like high school for another four years
and so they really seemed so young to me
uh like the ways they thought about the
world and plus there were all these sort
of cultural and class differences as
well between me and them
um so initially I did my best to sort of
fit in and to try to um fit in is the
right word but like try to try to like
Bridge divides and try to like take an
interest and make friends and so on and
it worked initially but then yeah the
the a lot of the sort of the the class
and cultural divides became so apparent
especially like you know once I learned
about like how much sort of activism and
how much
um you know at that point cancel culture
didn't yet exist but it was starting and
I was seeing students trying to get
professors fired trying to ostracize
students trying to pressure the
president and the administration to bend
to this and that demand and seeing
students claim that you know they they
were in danger or that uh words were
violence or harmful when I had spent you
know my early life living in like poor
and working-class communities I lived in
foster homes I was in the military and
now I'm in one of the like most it was
probably the safest and cleanest and
nicest places I'd ever been and now I'm
seeing the children of millionaires say
they felt unsafe at this you know fancy
rich college and I'm like what is
happening here and so that like that
kind of um
you know that that was that it was
exasperating to see all of that and that
was like my introduction to what that
was like and that's why I've you know
this sort of all of these experiences
informed this luxury beliefs idea of
like this is where it all came from this
is fascinating me because
um take random student says that they
feel unsafe do you believe that they
actually thought they were unsafe and
the reason why I asked that is like how
much of it is if you've never been
exposed to any of those other situations
like this actually may be the most
unsafe thing that you've ever done but
going back to the idea of like the nanny
is constantly coddling you right like
living on your own is unsafe yeah right
like you've never had to experience
anything in the world now all of a
sudden somebody says something mean to
you like it's literally they might as
well shoot you like it's the worst thing
that ever happened to you or do you
think it's just complete [__] I
think it's it's it's both I think that
there are I think there are true
believers who like legitimately feel
um some kind of anxiety or panic when
they're challenged on their views or
when they hear something that they
disagree with it really feels uh like an
existential crisis to them that someone
could challenge that
um and then I think there are a lot of
others who are sort of cynical they're
duplicitous like they understand that in
the game yeah they know that if they use
certain buzzwords that they're they're
odds of gaining some kind of Advantage
increase and I would say like those
that's probably uh like the numerical
minority maybe 20 30 of people think
that way I would think like the vast
majority like when they say they feel
unsafe like they literally feel like oh
like I feel physically uncomfortable and
they equate that with a sense of danger
maybe because they've never experienced
any kind of hardship before I mean I
think even things like like like
um physical soreness or injury I mean
interestingly like a lot of the people
that I got along with were like well
other veterans or like athletes or
people who had summer jobs you know
these like students who had those kinds
of experiences were like they were
physical in some way before they spent
you know now they're on a campus and
they're spending a lot of time in a
classroom
um someone who like understands like
that physical part of life they're like
actually pain and suffering and danger
like you know it's an actual like
physical embodied thing there's a
difference between that and you know
hearing someone insult you or say
something rude or impolite or
inconsiderate or or even offensive right
like there's a difference between
between those things and a lot of these
students a lot of these a lot of
graduates of these places like they
never really learn even even small
things like like driving I realize like
like there's like recent studies showing
that like a lot of young people don't
want to drive anymore
um and I think like there's this there's
this kind of like this fear of like
being unsafe being uh in a in a position
where they could potentially be in
danger not just like physically like oh
another car could hit you but like the
feeling of driving is like it feels you
know like like uh uh you could
potentially be at risk and so I saw this
with like a lot of these students right
like you go you know they get their
license maybe when they're 17 years old
or something they go to college then
they take Ubers and they've never
actually they've never even had to drive
which was like this is like a weird
thing but like this is something that I
noticed like I picked up on because like
in the military like I was driving you
could you have to to get to work to
commute and so on and then I get to
College like these kids don't know how
to like have a license but they don't
know how to drive they're scared of
driving you know like I rented some car
I rented a car with some friends they're
like hey can you drive Rob because like
I don't know like why don't you drive
like I was it was amusing for me to like
watch them drive because I'm like you're
an adult and you don't know how to drive
a car like what's wrong with you so yeah
this is um oh yeah the the standards are
are just you know different depending on
on like how fast you grow up you know
what is uh what's fascinating about what
you're describing is uh I was in college
then I deployed and I came back to
college and I might as well have been
two different people right because of a
lot of these experiences and um if I had
to point to one thing it was like
the people in college who have never had
some of these other experiences like
college is the bubble it is the world
right of like everything that exists in
my life is like on this campus or like
within you know two miles of it what
parties the people like all this stuff
maybe I heard about something on the
Internet that happened somewhere else
but like that's like basically might as
well be in a you know a different
continent right I am everything about
their life is like insular in that
college campus the second that anyone
has like real life experience and they
go to college campus like these people
are [__] insane like you're looking
at you feel like almost like you're like
staring into a snow globe right
right and that's great yeah like you
kind of like got outside right and now
you're like looking in and you're like
by the way like I get how it works
inside the snow globe yeah and like yeah
I can get in there and like I can
pretend to walk down the street you know
I can pretend to sit in the classroom
sure I'll play along right but you
realize like there is something outside
of the snow globe yeah and I've always
thought that like man how impactful
would it be just
well there was two months before people
went to a college or whatever you don't
have to send them around the world yeah
but like just some other experience
outside of just like classroom from K-12
that you could give them so they
realized like you are in a snow globe
yeah right and like how much would that
change the college experience because it
actually probably they would learn more
they'd probably take more seriously like
there's all these things that they would
get from it and you don't have to do
anything other than just like put them
in a different environment for some
short period of time let them see
something else and then put them right
back and like could you I don't know if
I told you that increased test scores by
you know 10 or they got you know better
jobs at the end or whatever people would
rush to do it we just don't think of it
that way yeah yeah I think yeah well
well having those experiences yeah if
it's um especially if there's a bit of
suffering and a bit of struggle and a
bit of sort of problem solving involved
I think I can go like yeah that can go a
long way uh instead of you know like a
lot of a lot of you know they'll take
like a gap year but then they'll travel
to Paris or something you know like
that's not
[Music]
because they've gone to other you know
rich countries in in expensive cities
you know that they feel like they're
sort of worldly or sophisticated but you
know instead it might be worth going to
like a developing country somewhere
they're more impoverished or even within
your own country to find find a place
and just you know get a summer job
working minimum wage and like renting
your own apartment and just living that
life for a little while just to see what
it's like before you go on to you know
go on to to the bubble so yeah I think
that could that could go a long way
um a lot of people talk about national
service I don't I don't necessarily
think that's feasible you know whether
it's military or like Peace Corps or
something else like
I think it would be nice in an Ideal
World I think practically it would be
very difficult to implement but you know
in in
what what what young people could do you
know when they're 18 is to just sort of
on their own decide like before I go off
to college I'll take a gap year and do
something um
so I have a friend who thinks that uh we
should send every High School senior for
a week to pick up trash in our local
town that would be great yeah and I'm
asking why he was like forget like all
the hardship and all this stuff he's
like how many high school seniors have
walked around their own town yeah right
like in today's day and age like they
sit in a room somewhere and they press a
button and [__] shows up Right Packages
food cars like like literally he's like
how many of them could even tell you the
names of the streets from memories of
Their Own Town yeah and I'm like man
that's great yeah and then you know he's
like and then pick up trash because like
well if you're gonna walk the street you
might as well like do something yeah and
so it's fascinating to me like that's
such like a stupid idea yeah but like
yeah actually I bet you most high school
seniors probably have not walked around
yeah miles of their local town in kanama
streets yeah I think yeah that's that's
yeah that's interesting that this this
is kind of a new phenomenon that like
now they don't know the names of the
streets or or even traveled much further
than than you know a few blocks within
their neighborhood
um I think also having that sort of um
having those difficult experiences
struggling a little bit and sort of
building up those inner reserves of
stamina can be important too
uh I I watched this Tick Tock video a
few weeks ago of this kid
um or this you know this young army
recruit going around his bunk and uh and
he was asking these these other guys uh
hey you know hey Jones if you could talk
to your recruiter right now what would
you tell him and all these you know
these are like 18 19 year olds and
they're like you know I'd say [__] you
or like I hate you or why did you do
this to me and so on and I'm watching
this and I'm like man like other other
young people are going to watch this and
they're gonna think like oh the military
sucks blah blah I'm not going to join or
if they were going to join maybe this is
going to change their mind but the thing
is like
in the moment it does suck like I as I
watch this I have these memories of like
yeah like I know how they feel like
that's awful like because your recruiter
tells you one thing and then things kind
of go did you do push-ups exactly and uh
but like for the rest of my life at
least like as I think back and I talk to
other guys about this maybe you've had
this experience too we're like you can
look back on that like I went through
that and I feel stronger now and I know
that like I can handle other challenges
now as a result of those experiences
or like however much life sucks now at
least like you know I didn't pull like
two all-nighters and now they're making
me run 10 miles or something like that
right now I can now you know what you're
capable of you sort of know uh where the
edges of your your your strengths are uh
but in the moment right like yes it
sucks and and I think we sort of uh you
know cultures are going in this
direction we're like no one should ever
feel any discomfort no one should suffer
any more than they have to like no one
should do anything they don't have to do
and so on and there's some truth to that
but when you're young I think it's
important to sort of test yourself a
little bit and it's important to to
struggle a bit uh as well I mean you
know thinking about like all the the
difficult things that I did as a kid and
like now like I'll give you so so I had
a I had a teacher in high school and and
I always remember this even when I was
young there was something that clicked
for me
at a teacher in high school who worked
at a lumber mill before he became a
teacher
and so I remember one day in class
um I was like I don't know maybe 15 16
years old one of the students asked him
uh is it hard being a teacher and he
responded like no like oh yes is it hard
work being a teacher and the teacher's
like that's not hard work being a
teacher he's like I'm sitting here
sipping coffee reading books with you
guys in an air-conditioned building he's
like I used to work at a lumber mill
he's like back-breaking work you know 10
hours a day sunburned like you know he's
just sweating like he couldn't sit down
you couldn't even he was like telling
you we couldn't even talk like sometimes
I talked about like the the manager
would be like hey no talking you know
back to work like that kind of job right
and now you're a teacher No One controls
he's like and so like he understood
right like how how fortunate his life is
now and so now like when you when you go
from like that kind of physical labor to
like working a more sort of White Collar
uh sedentary job you understand like how
lucky you are right how many of your
college friends or like your high school
friends
or were they very different they're
they're so so different man
um I just had
just had lunch with a friend of mine
from college so I was I was just on the
west coast you know visiting and um
a friend of mine one of my oldest
friends I lived with him my senior year
of high school and he caught me up on
what was going on with our high school
friends and you know so talk yeah yeah
one of those like hey what's going on
with people you know what's going on
with so and so what happened to him and
uh and like him so I had five close
friends in high school so there were six
of us none of the six of us and this is
like this is common where I grew up in
California none of the six of us were
raised by both of our birth parents so
it was me raised in foster homes my
friend that I met uh you know just uh
recently he was raised by a single dad
who had been married and divorced five
times another friend raised by a single
mom another friend raised by his grandma
because his dad went to prison and his
mom was addicted to drugs like this is
like you know this these were the
stories of where I came from and so my
friend is telling me about uh you know
all these guys we went to high school
with and like you know one of them
recently went back to prison the other
one recently reconnected with his dad so
he grew up his whole life never knowing
his dad right
his dad contacts him out of the blue on
Facebook and I was like hey son I want
to meet with you they go to meet at a
restaurant and my friend my old you know
we haven't talked in a few years but
he's talking to this he's like like
where like what I never you've been gone
my whole life now you want to like
re-enter and be my dad this is
ridiculous
and they talked for a little while and
it seemed like it wasn't going in a good
direction and then suddenly they're
doing cocaine in the bathroom together
right like the dad thought that like the
way to get his son back my friend back
into his life was to bust out the drugs
because he knew my friend like they both
been you know uh involved with drugs
before and so like those are the you
know that's you know what I mean like
these like these kind of like a
father-son ripping along right exactly
like literally they're at a diner
ripping a line you know doing cocaine
together and like that was the kind of
guy this he was which is kind of
unsurprising because he'd not been in my
friend's life and so that's who he was
and yeah other friends you know just
sort of menial jobs you know like the
this friend that I met had like like
sort of the best life out of the six of
us because he joined the Air Force like
I did and now he's sort of in this
holding pattern you know taking one
class at a time at Community College
working part-time at a restaurant like
his life is like okay but
um yeah that's like those are that's
sort of and then my college friends
right like completely different yeah
guys working at hedge funds guys working
in consultancies Tech like just wild
also ripping lines in the bathroom right
right but that's Adderall not uh not
okay and uh and so it's just uh I get
this sense of Whiplash and I'm I'm like
it's still like a this sort of a
conflict for me of like how to do this
about like how to how to go back and and
still remain you know to keep those ties
going with my old friends because I
don't want to lose that
um but then to have these new you know
these new friends this new set of
friends who I like too and and we get
along for different reasons
but yeah to sort of walk that tightrope
who are you more comfortable talking
with
Ah that's a tough question
um
I'm comfortable talking with each group
more comfortable about different things
so with my high school friends I'm more
comfortable talking about like
like past mistakes and failures and you
know the stupid things that we did as
kids and and my concerns about some of
the things I'm doing now and
relationship stuff family stuff like
personal personal issues I'm more
comfortable talking with my high school
because we go back right like they've
been known each other since we were kids
right well then they have context too
and with my college friends I'm more
comfortable talking with them about like
successes and professional stuff and you
know what uh what my expectations are
for the future right like I I tiptoe
around those things with with my high
school friends because I know there's
like our lives have gone in such
completely different directions that it
just feels weird to talk about like how
well things have gone for me now
um that I don't want to bring it up and
it doesn't feel right to like if you
know I just I'd rather not bring that up
with them this is very common by the way
yeah I talked to tons and tons of my
friends about you know hey how many of
your friends at other points in your
life doesn't have to just be you know
middle school or high school could be
your college friends could be maybe at a
first job or whatever but just like how
many of them do you still talk to just
about anything usually what I find is
the more successful that people are the
lower the number ends up being yeah and
I used to think like man like that'd be
horrible to like lose connection with
these people like did you get too good
for them right but then what you find if
you really start to unpack and ask them
is they're like
hey the things that I talk about with my
current friends I I can't talk about
with my old friends they won't
understand they don't get it they you
know all these different things and so I
have a friend who he's still very close
with uh what I'll call his childhood
friends this group I don't know eight
ten of them whatever it is and he's a
very successful Tech uh founder
he cannot talk about anything that he
does on a day-to-day basis because they
either one think of that he's like
bragging right or two they're like oh
the rich guy right right like they're
giving him [__] but like there's an
undertone of like hey you're different
than us and now this guy comes from a
different country so like all of his
friends are still back in his home
country and so like there's even that
whatever but remember like really kind
of unpacking it with him and he's like
dude he you know he went and he met
somebody who's like a well-known
investor and he's like if I tell my
friends that I did that they will
literally mock me either relentlessly or
they will stop talking to me because
they're gonna think I'm an [__] yeah
and he's like so I have to like have a
new set of friends for this new point of
my life that I can have these
conversations with where like they also
went and met that person right like like
it's not they wouldn't even think twice
that I bring it up yeah and instead we
can strategize about like maybe what to
say in the meeting or what the takeaways
were completely different you know kind
of receptivity to the same exact event
just based on where people are in their
life and when you knew them it's very
interesting yeah yeah that
um that
the fear of you know your friends like
uh thinking you're too good for them or
so I think that's oh I think a lot of
people think that what happens in these
kind of situations is you know a friend
becomes very successful a person becomes
very successful and they think they're
too good for the friends and that's why
they lose friends along the way that's
why you know as you climb upward you
have fewer and fewer of those those
friends from the old neighborhood often
what happens is actually it's the people
from the old neighborhood Who sever ties
with you because they feel
jealous or they feel you know
self-conscious and adequate something
like because we all came from the same
place but now one of us is doing better
and like it it's it it stings a little
bit and you don't necessarily want to
remain in contact with that person
because it reminds you of that and I
understand that but yeah I've lost
friends like I've gone out of my way to
try to retain ties and some of these
guys just don't want to you know they
don't they don't talk and it's I don't
think it's anything that I I did to them
it's just they you know for for whatever
reason they've decided to severtise and
I think it's related to that reason of
like being reminded and so do you think
they know why when you guys were all in
high school like could you have picked
who would be the like breakouts versus
not so so the the friend that I had just
recently met with uh that I mentioned
before so I I asked him I was like hey
what was your GPA when you graduated
high school he said it was 1.6 and I
said mine was 2.2 and so like 1.62. I
was like did I have the highest GPA out
of all those with 2.2 or that's a c
minus average and my friend had like a
deer or a d plug us and I'm like sorry
and I was like I don't you know some of
these other friends I don't talk like
what was their GPA but like probably not
right because like if the if the the
variance is 1.6 to 2.2 like I don't
think you're gonna feel oh the 2.2 he's
on his way to you know he's on his way
to great things I don't think so
um you know I looked at my old report
card recently and I there somehow my
high school offered a psychology class I
don't even remember taking it I don't
remember going but I got a C minus in it
and I'm like okay so C minus in high
school psychology that I don't remember
going to and now I have a PhD in
Psychology and so I don't think that
anyone would have you know connected
those dots maybe some of the more uh
observant teachers or like my guidance
counselor who kind of saw something in
me maybe they would have but I think it
yeah it would have you would have had to
like spend a lot of time with us to
really see it because we were all doing
the exact same stupid things all the
time why do you think you didn't do well
in school
I mean there were a lot of reasons uh
you know I was living with so many
different families all the foster homes
uh like lack of supervision
um in uh you know among among uh you
know the adult figures in my life
um yeah maybe kind of the kinds of
friends I made the kinds of friends I
was drawn to my
um lack of belief in myself I didn't
really think that I I was a smart person
or I or it was a some some some conflict
of like I didn't want to believe I was
smart but then if I was smart I didn't
want to accept that because then I would
have had to raise my sights for myself
and I didn't want to do that
um it was just easier for me to believe
that I wasn't capable of it
um yeah there was just a lot of like
inner turmoil and conflict going on just
from all of the you know all of the sort
of chaos and and the trials of that
period of of my early life
um and then it wasn't until I was in a
stable place in the military where like
I had predictability I had structure I
had uh mentors that I could count on and
rely on and I had like a you know I made
friends in the military too solid group
of friends uh who had had um I mean that
was the military was like the first time
that I met people who who like you know
regularly referenced their mom and dad
in the same sentence because they were
married and like hey I'm gonna visit my
mom and dad for Christmas and I'm like
your mom and your dad in the same house
like together like oh that's nice like
I'd meet them I'd go to meet their
families and I'm like this it started to
help me to recognize like I could have a
life like this if I wanted like you know
I could um
one of the things that I've always
realized is
um I would go to people's houses uh
military-wise or uh just through the
years in school and stuff
and I will be like
this seems like too perfect like I don't
know it was like this very weird thing
where there's one person in particular I
want to say who they are but I was in
Middle School and I remember I went uh
and I uh slept over at his house and we
woke up in the morning and his mom was
making Crepes and I'd never heard of a
[__] crepe in my life yeah and I
remember being like
does your mom do this like every morning
and he was like well yeah like on the
weekends I remember being like
you guys don't eat like Pop-Tarts like
she literally was there like pouring it
and like doing and I just remember
thinking to myself like this is wild
yeah yeah and I don't know like for you
you've had such like this like uh
tumultuous childhood to then go into
that environment did it seem almost like
too good to be true or like fake or what
uh yeah well now yeah
um I I try not to dwell on it actually
um
now like in the military it did seem
like wow my life is so different now but
I was kind of I was still relatively
young and unsophisticated you know 18 19
20. I I didn't have like a lot of deep
thoughts about it but I did start to
think like yeah maybe I could build a
better life for myself maybe yeah it was
sort of this aspirational and this
feeling of like yeah these like my you
know I I had a roommate uh in the
military we got a house together off
base once we'd reached a certain you
know Rank and met his family his parents
helped us move furniture into this house
that we were renting and like just to
see their interactions together and I
remember like feeling this like it was
like this feeling in my chest of like
this is so nice like I want this someday
for like my family of like helping my
son move into his first house or
something
um and um
yeah but now now it's like I say you
know I sort of like look at how my life
is going and uh and think about where I
came from and it's just it's it's almost
too overwhelming uh and this is one of
the reasons why I write is like that
helps me to sort of process it
um and sort of to like untangle this
like ball of yarn into like really sort
of unpack what I really think about this
and it helps me just sort of like uh uh
mentally uh process it all
um but yeah it's it's it's difficult
so you have a book coming out in
February yeah uh A Memoir of foster care
family and social class the book was
called troubled
um when you sit down to write something
like this how much of it is uh therapy
therapy and like therapeutic kind of
like what you're talking about now
versus uh you have to work to remember
things like you just sit down you're
just like well I remember you know day
one here we go or is it something where
like you really have to kind of work to
kind of put together
um a memoir like this uh it is a lot of
work
um more than I expected if I
if I had known it in advance how hard it
was going to be I probably wouldn't have
done it interesting um and so I'm glad
I'm actually glad I didn't know because
then it forced me to sit down and
actually do the thing
um and and I'm happy with how it turned
out but yeah it was uh you know it's so
so up until the point that I wrote that
most of my writing was like sort of
intellectual academic you know writing
research papers writing you know PhD
stuff you know this uh more sort of um
uh from like a pop Science pop
psychology perspective a lot of my
popular writing is that way but then to
to write from an emotional perspective
of my early life like it used like
different areas of I mean literally just
different areas of the brain it like
draws on a different source of energy
um and memory and all of those things
and so it was way harder actually like
writing my PhD thesis was way easier
actually than right like I wrote the
book first then I wrote the PHD thesis
the PHD I mean it wasn't it wasn't easy
but it was like I know what to do I can
sit down here's you know here's the
structure here's how it goes boom boom
boom but with this book it's like here's
a whole like bunch of things that
happened to me how do I like shape it
into something that makes coherent sense
and to sort of like highlight certain
things that I think are important in
certain themes like what lessons did I
learn from all of this did anything
important can I can I draw anything
important out of this to like help the
reader to understand what occurred
um and then yeah like sort of living in
that that world you know talking to my
sister talking to my old friends and
trying to like rekindle all of those
memories and I was so immersed in this
is during the lockdown when I wrote it
2020 2021 that um yeah I was so immersed
in it that you know like I would um I
would like buy food that I would eat as
a kid and try to smell it to like you
know because memory and smell are
actually that's that's the sense that's
most tightly linked to memory is is
smell and so I would smell the food I
would try to like I would listen to
music from that era and so I'd be like
asleep sometimes so immersed in it I
would I would be both awake at 3am a
memory would occur to me in a dream or
just like somehow while I was uh in that
unconscious State and I'd like run in my
computer and like type it out before I
forgot like man I haven't thought about
that in years
um and yeah it was just uh it was a very
like difficult and draining experience
and uh and I was actually like very it's
funny so during the lockdown I would
like take naps in the middle of the day
and I thought it was because of like you
know covid lockdowns the world shut down
I'm like you know it was like depressing
right like I think everyone got like a
little bit you know a lot of people got
a little bit depressed during that
period how fast things had changed and
so I was taking these naps and I was
like yeah just you know lock down
depression I guess and then it wasn't
until later that I realized like oh I
wasn't depressed as well I was depressed
I was writing this book and thinking
about all these things like that was so
emotionally draining that I was taking
naps which I don't usually do uh to sort
of deal with it and so yeah a lot of
these um a lot of these things sort of
expressed themselves physically in
unexpected ways yeah that's fascinating
what do you want people to take away
from the book like when you write a
memoir and you put everything you've put
into this book right in terms of some of
these things are difficult for you to
think about you were depressed writing
the book like like this is not a book
where you're writing about like look how
amazing I am and how uh you know my epic
run to winning an Olympic gold medal
right I knew from day one I was gonna do
that
what do you hope people can learn from
it yeah yeah I mean what yeah from from
the process I mean
yeah I think you can you can sort of
remember periods of your life where you
demonstrated like unexpected strength
and
to recognize like the small acts of
kindness that people did for you along
the way I think like gratitude is not
really like um uh uh popular or or
promoted in our culture and and when it
is it's people think it's like trite or
cliche oh like be thankful and people
just dismiss it as like this kind of
like oh okay fortune cookie wisdom or
something it's like actually like there
were despite the uh instability of my
life like there were people along the
way who uh expressed like unexpected
kindnesses did nice things for me that
they didn't have to do went out of their
way to like see that I could use help
and like in the moment I didn't really
understand just how um
yeah just just how how much how like how
how powerful that act would be for me
later or how much it actually helped me
um just because I wasn't I wasn't that
reflective back then and now to like
recognize oh wow a lot of people did
nice these nice things and to added to
think about it and then try to pay it
forward as well you know like for me a
lot of these people like I lost contact
with them there's not a lot I can sort
of like I just feel this um
uh desire to reciprocate like Define
these people say like hey remember that
time you told me just like like a small
comment that uh that meant a lot to me
in the moment I'll never be able to find
that person again but then to just you
know remember to say nice things to
other people or highlight you know when
someone does something meaningful or
important or goes out of their way to do
their best to to bring it up to them and
and tell them uh that it's that you
appreciate it I think that can go a long
way
I asked Paulina what questions she
wanted me to ask you and she said just
ask them this one thing because I think
it encapsulates so much of his life do
you still feel like an outsider or do
you now feel like you've kind of broken
through and have somehow become an
Insider oh uh no I I think like weirdly
um now I feel like an outsider even when
I in the places where I used to be an
Insider meaning where I grew up
interesting um now because I'm in this
environment now with like you know a
bunch of people who graduated from
college and work these kinds of uh jobs
and and and uh live comfortable lives
now when I go back home
talk to my old friends or talk to talk
to my members of My adoptive family
um I feel like an outsider there too now
um I talk to military friends you know
all of it I mean it's I feel like an
Insider and an outsider at the same time
I still feel mostly like uh uh an
outsider yeah mostly like an outsider
I don't know if that ever changes yeah
right but um for those uh who are
interested the book troubled Rob
Henderson A Memoir of foster care family
and social class it comes out in
February so I believe you can now go
Amazon everywhere else and pre-order it
um and then maybe we'll do this again
before uh before the book actually comes
out and kind of go through in detail uh
some of the stories that you have in
here because I think it could have been
for a lot of people so I appreciate you
taking the time to write the book but
also coming on here and talking and uh
where can we send people to find you on
the internet yeah yeah you can follow me
on Twitter at Rob K Henderson you can
follow my sub stack
robhenderson.substack.com and uh yeah I
mean if you sign up for my my sub stack
email list I'll announce uh you know all
the details about the book I'll probably
share some early chapters and excerpts
and things like that if you're if people
are curious before they decide to
pre-order to Rob K henderson.subsack.com
that's right yeah thank you so much for
doing this we'll do it again thanks
Anthony